i was playing d d this past weekend and
it got me thinking about something
really interesting here something that
i don't think most people think of in
their day-to-day life as an exercise
think of like the biggest franchises you
can think of pretty common ones come to
mind think of like marvel you think of
like iron man and superheroes and all
this stuff you think of like disney and
pixar and all these cartoons even think
of star wars star wars it's huge huge
franchise all these movies so much money
has been made of this try making a
superman movie or try making an ironman
movie try making a star wars movie you
know what i mean it's not gonna happen
and and that's because of our current
state of affairs and copyright control
all these franchises have these giant
fictional narrative universes that
everyone knows all about but there's one
special one that you already know all
about but is it it's special and it's
different from all the rest and that is
the shared fantasy universe
it's kind of like the open source of
fiction right
now everyone needs to take a moment to
appreciate the shared fantasy universe
it's it's because it has a deep rooted
history in human culture dragons elves
dwarves all this stuff these concepts
have been around in folklore and oral
and written storytelling have been
passed down from generation to
generation and lead us to today and lead
us to incredible pieces of content that
everyone knows and loves like lord of
the rings game of thrones
stranger things
when the kids open the books the d d
books and stranger things and look up
the demi gorgon they look up the mind
flare yeah well maybe it's not actually
a demigorgon and maybe it's not actually
mine flare but the thing is they're
using and they're tapping into this
shared fantasy universe to create new
stories
this shared fantasy universe is the one
that everyone gets to adapt and explore
and exploit for their own purposes i i
really like the phrase open source of
fiction because it does a really good
job explaining its its role and its
significance everyone thinks of game of
thrones as a franchise within itself but
really at its core game of thrones is no
more than lord of the rings fan fiction
i mean that is what happened george r
martin read lord of the rings and the
hobbit and was like you know what i love
this universe i'm gonna make my own
version of it and what's cool is is this
all kind of comes back to dungeons and
dragons because dungeons and dragons
is a storytelling tool set within this
universe when you watch game of thrones
you're like oh well i know how this
universe operates well there's obviously
some magic there's some dragons there's
some castles we get it you know it's
we're not concerned about that stuff
we're just thinking about the characters
within that story but we live in a time
of very intense copyright control and
there's a lot of people out there who if
had the opportunity to somehow own part
of this fantasy universe they would
prevent other people from adapting it
and using it as their own i'd like to
take a moment to talk about learning
about education about learning how to do
what you want to do in particular right
now i'm going to talk about learning how
to do filmmaking so this video is
sponsored by skillshare i actually do a
lot of my learning online other people
who are gracious enough to share their
skills and their knowledge with not only
me but anybody else who's looking it up
i know a lot of you are interested in
filmmaking are filmmakers yourselves you
might find this part a little bit useful
there's actually a couple interesting
video tutorials that i actually looked
up on skillshare before making this
video one was by a guy named phil ebener
which is actually how to make your
webcam videos look good now if you guys
have followed us on patreon and been
part of the hangouts our our video
quality on the hangouts isn't always the
best but now that i watch this tutorial
it's gonna be better back in the day
when i was learning how to make videos
how to make movies i mean i still am you
never stop learning when i was really
kind of cutting my teeth on all this
stuff with sam we would spend a lot of
time reading lessons and tutorials from
other people online there wasn't a whole
lot of actual nitty gritty filmmaking
teaching happening in our high school
we didn't really have books that delved
into that kind of stuff the best way for
us to learn was to actually go online
and learn from other people that were
doing it who are gracious enough to
share their skills and their knowledge
with us back when i was younger like 14
15 years old sam and i were learning how
to make videos and do visual effects
when we made our star wars fan film
which is
on our corridor channel we didn't know
how to make lightsabers we needed to
learn how to do lightsabers ryan weber
at the time had made a great lightsaber
tutorial effects on how to do them from
learning from his skills we were able to
do lightsabers something like skillshare
is great for that kind of learning
process if you want to learn from other
people sharing your stuff online
especially in a very clean curated
presented way skillshare is perfect for
that there's a link in the description
below it's a free two-month trial
membership they have a lot of lessons
they actually have over 15 000 lessons
on the site covering a huge range of
topics if you want to check it out you
can watch a lot of videos in two months
so you can find out if it's actually
something that you find useful or not
that's the speed of my education that
you hear revving up
just imagine if somehow someone just
imagine if someone managed to copyright
dragons like imagine imagine where that
would put us today all the works and all
the narratives that wouldn't exist
because of that i think it's probably
the time to talk a little bit about
copyright law because it's very
important when you're dealing with
fiction and and and works of art here
you know copyright protects the creators
of that work when the u.s first had its
copyright laws copyright only lasted for
14 years okay and now i admit that's
pretty short that's pretty that's that's
not even that long um eventually it was
extended to about 56 years by around
1909. and you know what honestly if you
write a work of fiction or create a
piece of art 56 years of protection
that's that says that work is solely
yours
is probably enough because 56 years
that's more than a generation so if you
create something you know you are set
for the rest of your life
but
as we all know that's changed so there's
this thing called the mickey mouse curve
that's kind of interesting and if you
look at it you can see that every single
time the the character of mickey mouse
is about to lose its copyright copyright
law
extends by decades and obviously it's
not a coincidence and that's because
disney created a character and they
wanted to own that character far longer
than what they were legally allowed to
so what did they do they lobbied
congress they changed the law and if you
look at this curve you see it makes
sense because from a business standpoint
mickey mouse
is an asset a lot of people like look at
disney movies and these stories and go
oh well they're they are beloved stories
these are money making machines if you
imagine a world where copyright law
somehow
didn't extend disney would be a fraction
of the size they are today first time
mickey mouse was going to expire in cop
for copyright they changed the law to
say rather than 56 years copyright would
last the author's lifetime plus 50 years
so if i came up with a cool cool
character you would i would gain the
copyright for it for my entire lifetime
and then add 50 years onto that but that
wasn't long enough because around 1998
they had to change copyright law again
so rather than just being the author's
life plus 50 years it's now the author's
life plus 70 years or
120 years whatever's greater now that's
that was in 1998 and that's the last
time u.s copyright law was was defined
which means that mickey mouse is going
to expire again in 2023
five years from now are we gonna see
copyright law extend because of disney's
lobbying on congress
obviously avi obviously obviously
they've done it twice before they're
gonna do it a third time they are the
largest media company they're the
largest narrative company in in the
world but the thing is is that
what this is doing though it's turning
these stories that people tell each
other you know things that become
public works effectively and turning
them into privatized properties but if
you look at how disney got their start
disney got their start by taking shared
fantasy stories by using fairy tales
they all their first stories like snow
white peter pan alice in wonderland
cinderella pinocchio basically in the
public domain and they used those they
took them and they adapted them and then
they profited off them and they founded
their empire on this now for them to
start like that and then flip and start
actively working against copyright law
so it's harder for other people to do
that feels it feels a little it feels a
little unfair you know it feels a little
false disney's been around for decades
and a copyright law was the same today
as it was when they started well a lot
of the stories that they've adapted or
helped create would be in the public
domain and allow other people to adapt
them and work with them and cherish them
in their own unique ways everything we
know about copyright law today points
towards why the shared fantasy universe
is one of the most crucial and important
things we can hold on to right now i
personally believe in copyright i think
it's a good thing i don't think this
this is not about whether copyright is
good or bad because it definitely
protects our work you know we have a
youtube channel we create content
obviously we should be the people to
profit off it since we created it but
when does that end when should that end
at what point do our stories become
yours that's the real question here you
know you hear a story from a friend and
you tell that to another friend and you
tell that to another friend and it
changes and it adapts it stops becoming
my story starts becoming your story when
i was playing d that last weekend we had
a great time i thrust people into a
brand new story brand new setting brand
new characters in d you're encountering
monsters but you're running around with
magical swords there's all this lore
somehow
for some reason they knew exactly how
everything worked and that's because d
is in this shared fantasy universe and i
i kind of came to that realization then
when it's like wait a second the rules
and the stories and the creatures that
are all within these books we already
all know this is something that's that
everyone owns these these stories
they're ours you know they they're not
owned by anyone you're working on
something or you want to think of cool
ideas you know honestly picking up one
of these books is not a bad place to
start